Assassin's Creed Odyssey is the latest
game in the long-running franchise and
has been confirmed for release in
October this year for Xbox one ps4 and
PC coming hot off the heels of 2017 s
Assassin's Creed origins Odyssey seems
to be changing things up for the series
even more we already had a chance to
play the new game for a few hours and
experience many of its features
so here's six things new and assassin's
creed Odyssey that we think changed the
formula in interesting ways
the Sasa's Creed series is well known
for its historical backdrops this time
we're going acient Greece specifically
we'll be exploring in the year 413 BC in
the midst of the Peloponnesian War its
Sparta versus Athens but you're a
mercenary seeking revenge on those who
took your family away from you you'll be
traveling to lush locations around
Greece like Mykonos Delos and Attica to
name a few and meeting prominent
historical figures like Socrates
Hippocrates and he rode Otis you'll be
able to go through this Odyssey as
either a male protagonist named Alexios
or a female protagonist named Cassandra
they have the same story dialogue and
abilities the only difference is the
voice acting and character models it's a
similar approach to how Mass Effect had
both male and female shepherds
but it's up to you who you'll lead
across ancient Greece
picking the lead character isn't the
only decision you'll be making an
assassin's creed Odyssey for the first
time in franchise history dialog options
will permeate the entire adventure there
will be opportunities to tease out more
information during conversations but
some decisions can impact how the game
plays out certain NPCs can also be
romance or befriended depending on what
you say
Ubisoft toyed with the idea of letting
players know whether or not certain
lines have an effect on outcomes similar
to telltale games but ultimately decided
it would be better for players to not
worry about making the optimal choice
[Music]
there will be consequences to your
actions for example the demo we play
prompted us to align with one or two
characters on how to approach leading a
rebellion
we chose the more subtle approach which
gave us a mission to sneakily take out
enemy weapons and supplies on foot had
we chose decide with the one suggesting
more brute force we would have had to
complete naval combat missions instead
it's not just about what you say to
other characters either side quests are
where it gets interesting
in one case socrates gave us a heads up
on a rebel being held hostage who could
help the fight but he's known to be a
loose cannon we can either free the
rebel kill him or ignore the quest
altogether since we decided to free this
character in the Socrates side quest he
appeared in the conclusion of a main
quest line but straight-up assassinated
an important character during what was
supposed to be a celebration this result
also damaged the relationship we had
with another character we can't say
socrates didn't warn us though that's
just one example of consequences in this
huge open world game
since Greece is a collection of islands
with lots of water to explore in the
middle it makes sense that's sailing
your own ship is core to a sea Odyssey
naval combat will also play a huge role
much like Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag
expect to destroy enemy ships with fire
aerobridges
waves of javelins or full-speed naval
rams
once ships reach zero health you can
loot them by hopping aboard and engaging
in traditional hand-to-hand combat ac
origins had a few instances of seafaring
battles but Odyssey is treading deeper
waters
[Music]
combat abilities and skill trees give
players plenty of options when it comes
to fights and assassinations holding the
left shoulder button turns the face
buttons into ability activations and the
left trigger does is for bow and arrow
abilities in total eight skills are
available to you at once a few notable
skills are a shield grip a healing
ability and a multi arrow shot but
nothing comes close to the iconic
spartan kick giving enemies the boot
will comically send them flying backward
ideal for launching them off ships or
off the side of a cliff this is sparta
after all these are a few of the new
things we saw with our short time in
ancient Greece so stick the game spot
for more on assassin's creed Odyssey
[Music]